افادت مراسله الجزيره باقتحام قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي قريه صير جنوب جنين
شمال الضفه الغربيه وحاصرت منزلا بدعوه
وجود مطلوب داخله واكدت مصادر محليه ان
قوات الاحتلال اطلقت النار صوب المنزل
وهددت بهدمه في حال عدم الاستجابه
لتعليمات القوات
الاسرائيليه معنا من قريه صير جنوب جنين
مراسله الجزيره جيفارا البديري يبدو اره
ان العمليه العسكريه الاسرائيليه في الضفه
الغربيه تمتد من قريه الى اخرى او من
منطقه الى اخرى ماذا يحدث في
جنين نحن في بلده صير محمود جنوبي جنين
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي موجوده في هذه
القريه منذ اكثر من خمس ساعات تمنع احد من
التحرك من الخروج والدخول بسهوله كما نرى
عبر عدسه الكاميرا هذه بعض الاليات
العسكريه الواضحه للعيان ولكن في الواقع
العمليه تستهدف منزل في داخل ال القريه
جنود الاحتلال ما علمناه قبل قليل رغم عدم
القدره لاي صحفي على الاقتراب ولكن جنود
الاحتلال بعد عمليات اطلاق نار متواصله
وكانت متقطعه خلال الساعات الماضيه كانت
تحاصر هذا المنزل تحديدا وا لكن الان الذي
نؤكد ان جنود الاحتلال الاسرائيلي هم في
داخل هذا البيت المكون من
طابقين ما تؤكده عدد من من افراد عائله
ابو الرب ان هذا البيت يعيش فيه اب واربع
ابناء له وان احد ابنائه مطلوب لدى
الاجهزه الامنيه الاسرائيليه واان قوات
الاحتلال تطالبه
بتسليم نفسه ولكن حتى هذه اللحظه خلال
النصف ساعه ال الماضيه لم نعد نسمع صوت
لاطلاق النار لانه كان هناك اطلاق نار
البعض يعني يؤكد ان اطلاق النار كان
متبادلا في البدايه ولكن ما نؤكد ان اطلاق
النار كان فقط من قبل جنود الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي اتجاه البيت عبر مكبرات الصوت
كانوا يطالبون من في داخل وتحديد اسم
بعينه
لخروج ولكن الان الجنود اصبحوا داخل
المنزل طواقم الاسعاف لا تستطيع الوصول
الى ال الى هذا المنزل المكون كما ذكرنا
من طابقين الى هذا المبنى لا احد يعرف
ماذا يحدث تحديدا في الداخل بعض وسائل
الاعلام تحدثت عن وجود شهيد لا وجود لشهيد
لانه حتى هذه اللحظه لا احد يستطيع
الاقتراب حتى بما في
ذلك طاقم الهلال الاحمر حاول الدخول
والوصول الا ان قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
بقوه الرصاص وجهت بنادقها اتجاه طاقم
الاسعاف منعته من الوصول اذا الاسئله
الثلاثه الان مطروحه هل تم اطلاق النار
على الشاب ودخلت بالتالي قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي الى الداخل ام هل استشهد الشاب
المطلوب هل كان مسلح ام لا وبالتالي لا
احد يعرف بالتحديد ما الذي يحدث داخل هذا
المبنى الذي كما نرى هو محاصر بالكامل قبل
قليل تم سماع اطلاق نار متبادل في احد
السهول القريبه من هنا راينا رتل كبير من
الاليات العسكريه تتوجه الى هناك ولكن
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ايضا منعت من
جديد الطواقم الطبيه من الوصول الى تلك
المنطقه وبالتالي ليس معروف بعد ان كان
هناك اصابات لم يعني لازالت الغموض يكتنف
بالكامل الهدف من هذه العمليه فقط ما هو
معلوم ان قوات الاحتلال تقوم بمطارده شاب
فلسطيني ايضا تم استجواب عدد من الشبان
هنا تم احتجازهم تكبيل ايديهم
وارجلهم كان هناك عدد من القناصه ينتشرون
على اسطح المنازل هنا وكان يتم اطلاق
النار قبل حوالي الساعه حتى قبل الساعه
على من يتحرك هنا ولكن حتى في هذه اللحظات
هدوء شامل ولكنه بالطبع مشوب بالحضر في
هذه المنطقه وكما ذكرت محمود بالطبع يعني
منذ السابع من اكتوبر في كل قريه فلسطينيه
وكل مدينه وكل بلده هناك اقتحامات سواء في
النهار في في الليل اصبح كل فلسطيني يحاول
التنقل طريقه يعني تكون خطيره جدا عند
وصولنا من رام الله الى هنا الى صير جنوب
نابلس الطرق محفوفه
بالمخاطر الكبيره وبت ولذلك مع ارتفاع عدد
الشهداء فقط شيء اخير الى
325 شهيدا واكثر من 5000 حاله اعتقال منذ
بدايه السابع من اكتوبر حتى اليوم شكرا لك
جيفاره البديري مراسله الجزيره في صير
جنوبيه جنين سنتابع معك اولا باول